he's a pipe in a pore in a tree in a -
in a WOM hello wonderful people welcome
to another episode of a genius brain I
am Joe chit Sakawa and I am David so
uh-huh and we like to talk about brain
genius thing yeah man you know there was
an interesting topic that it was funny
we were just in the car and we were
having a conversation about this we just
came back from eating some Burmese food
son a pork brain
shoutout to Nadi Myanmar cafe out in
Alhambra see always treating this real
nice we have a great relationship you
know I like those restaurants that we go
eat at and I've been there so often they
know who the [ __ ] I am man yeah has
nothing to do with my following they
just like you're that fat guy that used
to come here life kept their business
afloat yeah he's like yo you lost a lot
of weight now I know I haven't been here
in a minute man
not a and I checked myself real quick
all some good stuff though yeah man well
we when you look at one of the my
favorite things that I get there is this
thing called jail and it's this bowl
it's this noodle soup it's like Irby
it's salty it's sweet and then you read
all the ingredients and it just looks
like a bowl of garbage it's like all of
the pieces of a pork four people go I
don't want that part yeah pork intestine
pork brain I love how they were like
extra like careful to like you know
there's brain in there no just to let
you know we're throwing crap in there
there's a woman in there are you sure
it's like you don't know me lady cuz it
was a there was a new girl there she's
not she's usually not there so that
young girl that sauce was like huh yes
she's like the daughter of the person
who owns it okay and so the owner knows
you yeah there's other dude that's
usually there too and I haven't seen a
man I was kind of hoping to see him I
used to give that dude a hug I like when
new people are at the restaurant and
they don't know you're regular and you
feel like do you know this restaurant
you know like like you know what you
want D do I know what I want I know
exactly what I want [ __ ] this is what I
want come on now you know that ramen
place rock on in no Tokyo yeah
servers there to like have you been here
before I'm like yeah yeah I've been here
before you know that egg that you had
this all yogi yet thank me right yeah I
asked for soft-boiled eggs baby yeah we
made changes in restaurant that's how
dope it is but the conversation that we
were having in the car that was so
interested we yo man I'm pretty sure we
touched on this subject a lot but we
never really got into it a hundred
percent and it was just kind of like
that Asian parenting and everybody has a
different style of Asian parenting yeah
you know I think we had a very similar
one yeah that's why we could relate but
there's where we're we're on a more
extreme side of the spectrum of like
child abuse I feel like a lot of the
times when I think about this stuff I I
kind of go back in memory man I just get
my ass beat a lot I used to get beat up
all the time man and at the time to
fight I felt like it was super unjust
but dude I was a little [ __ ] so now
I'm thinking matica honey if I had a kid
like me I probably would kick his ass
too so I probably deserved it but at the
same time I don't know what I was doing
yet so people who haven't what their
kids I felt a lot of immigrant parents
take their kids asses a lot just because
you know when you're so busy trying to
start up a business you're broke you're
poor you don't know anybody because
that's what you were taught from your
parents and you just don't have a lot of
time to sit down and talk to you have to
be like yo these are the reasons why
you're doing something wrong it's way
easier just to sock them in the eye and
you're real quick okay maybe I shouldn't
it's like busy poor uneducated parents
yep or just super traditional parents
that like they got their asses beat and
all yeah yeah yeah I I started to
realize that later on when I just kind
of as an adult I look back at what my
parents were going through why they were
fighting a lot and when we were so
financially unstable go and up up I put
it to you like this
I talked to my my dad about this and I
was like I understand why you were so
mean when you were younger he goes what
do you mean I was like I'm with Muriel
now she's a [ __ ] I hated us because she
stresses me out you know so I understand
imagine that and you're younger and you
have kids and you're uneducated so it's
like do people at work are yelling at
Mia my wife is yelling at me my kids are
yelling at me I'm gonna flip the [ __ ]
out yeah and that's why I think my dad
was so high-strung yeah it makes sense
like he was he was strung out to the max
I'm surprised he didn't kill one of us
did he did he did he apologize or
anything like never said sorry to me man
but does he recognize that he went a
little too far or does he just suppress
those memories in his mind do we so my
dad and I had a really really big fight
a few years ago and the reason why is
because he and I have we've never really
seen eye-to-eye on a lot of things and
the biggest reason why do is because he
were actually very similar similar but
I'm the less extreme version of him yeah
and I am a little more open-minded than
him and it kind of all came out where he
was just he still has this habit of
wanting to tell me what to do with my
life and now it's it's good it's not it
you know you know even after like 30
years of living now it becomes in a way
where or it comes in a way where he says
it this is my advice you could take you
to leave it which is kind of nice but
he's leaning toward I hope you take it
because I'm writing you're wrong exactly
and it still kind of feels that way and
it's probably just from all the
ass-whoopin I got when I was a kid yeah
but we had this whole moment where I
flipped the [ __ ] out on him and I kind
of just emotionally burped blurted out
all the things I [ __ ] hated that he
did to me and it all came out yeah you
know and I told him I told him like yo
you know what here's the problem man
I was like you you always want me to do
the things your way and you always think
that it's right and you know you have to
realize that you're wrong a lot of the
times mhm you know you're wrong you know
and I started listing off all these
things that he that he [ __ ] up on like
for example when I was trying to go to
college and this is not a knock on my
debt I'm not talking [ __ ] about my dad
he always did the best that he could and
arguably like to his point he said that
I told him listen
you remember that time you told me that
I had to go to a university or if I
didn't go to a university
I wasn't don't ever call me your father
do you remember when you said that to me
and my dad said I never said that yeah
that's what I'm saying a lot of these
guys suppress yeah the [ __ ] that they
say in the [ __ ] that they do because
they do it out of impulse and I don't
remember [ __ ] and I do that [ __ ]
devastated me yeah like that he doesn't
he didn't know but when he said that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] shattered me like
anybody deny it it's even worse it makes
me even angrier you know so my brother
was there the like I forgot when it was
but I brought it back up and I said hey
do you remember he goes I don't remember
if I called my brother right now he
remembers when you said that to me in
the car you said it to me in the car in
the Isuzu Trooper you told me that I was
no longer your son and if I didn't
accept it like [ __ ] did I say that
my bad or does he just like no you're
wrong I didn't say that yeah or even if
he did he probably doesn't want to
remember it you know he's like on some
[ __ ] like that and then I also kind of
product yeah you know that's a big ego
man yeah it's hard dude and I also
brought up the time where I said to him
where I kind of wanted to force my
career choices right and I said to him
isn't that every freaking agent dad yeah
I was like yo man and I said to him and
I I wish you would have allowed me and
supported me in the things that I was
trying my best at yeah I was trying to
be a stand-up comic and I wish you would
have just supported me in that and I
probably would have been able to excel a
lot further than I am today I'm happy
where I'm at but you have to realize
that you messed up no matter how hard
you told me I shouldn't do something I
went the opposite and I did and I
excelled in it did he ever go like
because I gave you so much pressure you
succeeded so oh there was that tough to
do no matter what they do they were the
benefit yeah and in that conversation he
said don't you remember what I told you
I was gonna support you I was like no
you didn't say you were gonna support me
you said you were gonna support me if I
did it the way you told me to those
that's completely different so we had
this funny dude I you know I wanted to
put this in a film script because his
conversation was so funny he goes I
remember when I said I was gonna send
you to comedy College what the [ __ ] is
comedy College dude
said that yeah I was like dude there's
like you see you know like UCB and all
that other [ __ ] buddy come what is
comedy College did he even say he was
gonna send you to comedy College yeah
did he make that up
he just said on the spot like dad
there's no such thing as comedy College
there's like programs that you could get
to where you learn about theater or
stand-up and stuff like that what the
[ __ ] is comedy College and then the next
day after this fight he got he was so
[ __ ] petty right so petty that he
went on to my facebook he had a face but
and he sent me links to comedy colleges
it was like theater at [ __ ] Stanford
I was like hey jackass I still have to
get it to Stanford it's not like I was
so infuriated but that's how petty he
could be sometimes he has to be right he
has to be right and we had this huge
fight and during that day like I
remember he said something and it kind
of broke my heart because I told him was
like you [ __ ] up and you need to admit
that [ __ ] yeah you can't always think
that you're right and you know he said
to me I think how he took it was I was
telling him that he was a bad father
and he just looked at me he goes I did
the best that I could zero to 100 yeah
it's like you just gotta you just want
him to say there's a few things where I
did [ __ ] up and and I could have been a
better father at yeah it's just like he
wants you to think say that he's perfect
like what the [ __ ] did I say man my dad
90% of the time hit the nail on the head
yeah he was a great father but that 10%
where I wanted him to really support
what I wanted to do and you know I will
take responsibility for the fact that I
was very wishy-washy about things when I
was younger so for him he saw it as I'm
gonna make you work at this business I'm
a forced you to do these things because
if I don't you're going to be a bum and
you're not gonna make anything out of
your life yeah but if he would have sat
down and had a conversation with me like
my mom did he would have understood how
passionate I was about standup my mom
understood that so when she told me on
the side which I'm not sure if my dad
even knew this she says just graduate
get that college degree finish up and I
guarantee you for you you could I'll let
you do whatever you want just do that
for your dad so you could shut him up
and then after this go get a part-time
job and become a stand-up comedian go go
just do so she was like secret she was
the woman that was like brute like
supporting my dreams on the down low cuz
though you know
you would always defend me like you'll
get off his back get off his back and it
made me hate school even more yeah you
know that's crazy man it's like he tries
controlling you so much to the point
where it turns around and you resent him
and and even though you are pursuing
your dreams or whatever it's like great
at the expense of the relationship and I
think that happens to a lot of like
immigrant families yeah a lot dude like
I know my cousins they they resent they
resented their father for a long [ __ ]
time because he controlled what their
career paths were yeah so like my oldest
cousin I mean she had to do occupational
therapy like something in a medical
field they all had to do medical field
[ __ ] and then it's like they didn't do
they don't want to but he was just like
with the iron fist like you have to do
this and three years ago he told me you
know what the secret to life is and I'm
like what and he goes what you're doing
you need to you need to do what you want
to do and excel at it and then all of my
cousins were like he would have been
cool if you told us 40 years ago like
they're all like in their 40s and 50s in
jail you know and he's like yeah I
[ __ ] up so the cool thing is he's like
yeah I get it now and it took him a
while I mean he's like in his 80s now
yeah it's like all said and done right
but it was like [ __ ] that sucks it took
him that long and my dad - he didn't he
never apologized verbally but he did it
with his actions so when I when I left
to go pursue my dream here out here in
LA what my dad did was he actually
bought me an iMac it's like it's not
editing so he never supported you didn't
have to apologize but he always does it
through stuff like that's the way that's
that that's him telling you he's proud
of you yeah that's like 90s I'm saying
90% of the time he hit the nail on the
head that 10% that was it was a really
hard pill for me to swallow yeah cuz
that's the stuff that stuck with me a
lot so his intentions were always great
it's just communication wise he's never
been good at it I found out my dad is
actually kind of in that way with his
own children very socially awkward
uh-huh and people don't see that because
he goes what wasn't your father a pastor
true but when you're a pastor figure
especially in a Korean Church
you're not conversing with people you're
talking to people yeah you're like a
special person yes like you it's almost
like this like you know there's a
feeling of I need to mentor these people
yeah people look up to me and people
need me right it's very different from
your own family yes so he has those
personal social cues that he's learned
as a pastor when he's talking to as I
call him his sheep or his flock or
whatever the biblical term is and uh
conversing for my mom she's very good at
talking to anybody and everybody yeah
super fun I talked to my mom on the
phone so often during the week she knows
how to like not lecture you yeah right
we chop it up we crack up we laugh and
that's I think that is something that I
gained from my mom a lot she was very
opposite of my dad where most of his
conversations were based on lecturing
you know do this do that you should do
this you should do that and that was
that was the super hard part about
dealing with a parent yes crazy how do
you what are you gonna talk to me like a
person or an adult eventually that's not
that's the hard part and they do
eventually learn yeah
depending on who they are I mean I'm
lucky that my mom learned early yeah
like after my parents split when I was
in junior high I think that was a huge
wake-up call for her that's when she was
like [ __ ] what's going on cuz she said
that she never thought that she'd ever
be in a divorce like life really [ __ ]
hit her if she had to reevaluate like
what was life yeah and one of the things
that she told me was like she's been so
sheltered up until that point that it
was like a big wake-up call to start
thinking for herself yeah because she
grew up in this super religious like
yeah place where everything was
controlled her information like she was
like even books like she had to get
approval for novels and things she
wanted to read everything all the
information all the things in her world
was control sure she had no [ __ ] clue
about the outside world holy [ __ ]
so she try to control me that way and
she's like I can't believe she said that
she resented me as a child because I
wasn't someone that she wanted me to be
so it was that bad that's so often from
Asian people yeah it's it's like a it
was a conditional love right so if I'm
getting good grades or if I'm performing
the way that she wants me to then she's
like proud of me or she wants me and if
I'm not doing those things I don't exist
you know the mean so like I'm so she
said that that that's how her mom
parented her so she did that to me and
like she had this image of who she
wanted me to be yeah but obviously I'm
just a TV crazy ass kid that's just all
over the place yeah and you know I'm not
gonna be a good little boy the way that
she wants me to right yeah but she said
she had to wake up and learn like what's
going on like what did I cause for this
relationship to go sour in my in my
romantic relationship as well as my
relationship with my children yeah and
then I think hey your mom's woke as [ __ ]
dude I don't hear a lot of parents do
that [ __ ] I think I'm lucky because she
went through such a shitty time and she
had to self-reflect and she was
surrounded by people that were deep
thinkers yeah so my mom's kind of a ditz
yeah she is a valley girl but like when
it comes to what I love about her is
she's able to look at herself and go
what am I doing wrong yeah and and then
like try to fix that and then from my
junior high up until high school and on
I had a different mother
the very beginning I had that tiger mom
that was like mad at everything always
had to be her way all this [ __ ] very
stubborn you know whatever yeah
but then from high school and on she was
the complete opposite I was doing drugs
I was doing whatever the [ __ ] I want all
she wanted was a relationship with me so
she told me back then she realized like
all she was doing was rules right so I
grew up in a house where I'm being taken
care of by my grandma and that's a lot
of immigrant families where both parents
are working all [ __ ] day long yeah
and then the grandparents are taking
care of the kids right so my
relationship with my mother figure is my
grandma mmm and then so my mom comes
home from work and she just like barely
has time to tuck me in
or doesn't even see me at all he said I
don't have a connection with her lies at
that point she was a single mom no no
she was working she was a single mom the
right shoes no no she was see the single
mom at 14 so before that okay she was
working till like 7:00 p.m. okay I saw
my dad more than I saw my mom because my
dad would teach music at the house ah
okay yeah yeah yeah but and so but as
throughout my childhood um it was mainly
my interaction with my mom was rules so
I can't like when I did see her it was
like she's giving me homework or like
whatever or like she was teaching
Japanese at a language school so when I
interacted with her like it's a teacher
setting yeah so there wasn't much mom
kid interactions huh
so she realized that and she was like
[ __ ] like all throughout life like she's
so busy that she's just trying to like
all right discipline the rules so she's
like coming in cracking the whip and
then she goes so there's no like
playtime together yeah
so she's trying to build she try to
build back build that back up during
high school yeah so every chance she got
to just hang out go eat together
whatever she wanted to rebuild that
relationship yeah and we started having
long conversations and we just started
like going out to eat and like it
started getting really [ __ ] cool so
my dad leaving and all that stuff
created this like wise person who was
able to learn how to lose everything to
gain everything exactly yeah and I think
now it's like when I do have a
conversation with her she's not telling
me how to live life she's not telling me
what to do it's just like hey this is
what I learned yeah today it's pretty
crazy I hope I don't become that parent
though that's what I get scared of
sometimes where I'm thinking like dude I
hope I don't become the parent that's
just over parenting my kid yeah cuz I
feel like sometimes too like some some
people lose a sense of their selves when
they have a kid which is a good thing
too because you're giving a lot to your
children but I don't want to lose myself
as an individual so I've heard a lot of
moms say they a lot of young moms that I
know they're scared of people saying
like oh let's say your kid's name is I
don't know
white cut yeah yeah it's like oh you're
white cups mom yeah so they lose their
they lose their name I feel like I'm
giving tack a hell more attention every
time I come over like I'm not even
trying to talk to Bart in June yeah I
was like yeah well because we don't get
to see Tiger that often so I want to I
want to play with them and I want him to
remember me well that's true though a
lot of people they they put themselves
in their kid cuz they're like Oh your
kids not doing good or like that kids
annoying and and they take it personally
yeah I'm like dude that's a lot that's a
lot to think about man yeah it's just
it's kind of cool when you get to look
back and you get to see how much effort
your parents put into you because yeah
and it's I can't imagine being a parent
I can at the same time I don't know how
I would handle it I I have a lot of like
hypotheses and [ __ ] like I have a lot of
things that I think that I would do but
who really [ __ ] knows and I also
think like a lot of people just have to
forgive and move on yeah cuz mmm sure
our parents could have done better like
everybody could always do better but you
got to ask yourself like did they do
better than their parents they probably
did yeah
like I know some parents that are just
straight crack addicts but they did
better than their parents in in in a
twisted way like they did right like so
it's like they only have their own role
models in their own experience to go
from so our parents like we can't
compare them to fifth generation
Americanized you know family that's like
prestigious and educated they're not
gonna deal with problems like our
parents dealt with problems yeah my dad
though he has some had creative ways to
punish me though I do it has some
funny-ass ways this fool used to do this
thing back in the day
or he would stick out his fists and tell
me to punch my own face that's a Korean
thing and the unknown a lot of Korean
friends that had to deal with name [ __ ]
know what the [ __ ] is what kind of
sadistic [ __ ] is that dude and I punty
your own pace
my brother had ice bats my mom would do
ice baths and throw them in there that's
like some military [ __ ] why that takes
time you gotta make the pass you gotta
fill it with cold water you have to
throw [ __ ] ice cubes in there and
then throw your naked kid in there you
know what we call that we call that a
commitment to rage because most pee
well during that whole 20 minute ordeal
they would have calmed down my then yeah
they would have calmed down by the time
I went to the store I got all that ice
you know I went to the 7-eleven I
checked it out I came back home got into
the car I would have been done with I
know and I just would have had a bag of
ice for no [ __ ] reason but you know
Japanese and Korean people they're like
I'm gonna stick through this that'll
teach em yeah like I about dude I can
remember how many times I got my ass
beat it did you did you ever get like
beat by your dad and then sometimes when
you have confrontations at school and
these kids with their punch that you
like they should know your heart bro oh
yeah like I know anything is as scary as
yeah a parent Oh beating I was like
you're a little baby fist it feels
nothing like a bat to my ass just to put
just to put it in perspective I think I
was more scared of my uncle and like
other people too because my parents were
pretty crazy but not like them
that's so weird with Asian people - how
your people who aren't your direct
guardians could kick your ass and it's
okay at the church the church they're
like thankful yeah yeah like the church
members could kick my ass like what the
hell like I'm not safe ever
I have no safe house like I yeah guy
would get in trouble at church and now
we get slapped upside my head by some
stranger and then he would tell on me to
my parents like your kid did this that's
funny I would just slapped up the head
again I'm like yo this is not a safe
place I thought a church was supposed to
be a safe house it's kind of stupid to
like they don't know how to explain
things but if you notice like a lot of
Asians don't know how to explain things
and think because a lot of people didn't
they didn't have to date and get explain
things yeah it's just it's literally
like robots like you're just now it's
like this is common sense so you should
know already and then I'm gonna just
teach you the hard way Wow yeah and then
you grow up saying well [ __ ] yeah you
shouldn't be doing that and then you you
do it to the next generation but no one
knows what they're doing so there's a
lot of stupid Asians if you think about
it right like yeah yeah you're stupid as
in like people don't know how to reason
they're just what they're just they have
really good discipline they know what
they're supposed to do yeah
but it's everything is automatic and
there's no deep thought behind it yeah
so you can't really explain it it's kind
of like how we memorize math uh-huh like
you you can't explain it but then like
for us I grew up learning a rhyme for
multiplication yeah and like they'll
tell they'll tell you but then they said
just memorize at first it's easier
uh-huh so you go throughout life just
memorizing different things not knowing
the meaning behind it yeah yeah there's
sometimes too like I wonder I wonder if
I'm I wonder how my parents remember
things versus how I remember it
oh yeah they tell their story my story
is completely different
I had this recording that I'm trying to
find somewhere in the house where I had
an argument with my dad about the the
the color of the room that I wanted to
paint so we recorded it I saw check this
out so I so we had this argument where
we were redoing the house so he really
redid the outside my dad likes to fix
things sometimes he does a great job
sometimes he does it but it's his hobby
and he was allowing us to paint our room
whatever color that we wanted what do
you mean by whatever color that he
wanted it means the color that he
approves that's the freedom of choice
yeah that's the freedom that I had at
the house so this conversation is so
funny I wanted to paint my room a dark
blue as you can see as an adult I did it
yeah a dark blue and with white trim
that's what I liked I want it I wanted
that and then my dad goes no that
doesn't make sense
why what do you mean because I like it
he goes no it's not good I was like how
is it no I'm sorry I'm [ __ ] up the
story he says it's wrong that's what
that was the word that took it is wrong
to do it he goes it's wrong I was like
what do you mean it's wrong I was like
you asked me what color that in Korean
or in English he said in both because he
could speak English yeah yeah and if I
if he feels like I'm not understanding
what he said what he's saying in Korean
he'll say it in English but I understood
what you're saying in Korean yeah you're
just saying you're just pissing me off
in two languages so he goes it's wrong I
was like what do you mean it's wrong he
goes you can't have this is his words
because a dark color is heavy right you
can't have it on a light color because
it's light because it's like it's
crushing it so I was you just made that
[ __ ] I made that [ __ ] up on the spot
you crafty [ __ ] and he goes well
you can't have dark colors you can't
have heavy colors on light colors and I
just look like what are you talking
about all these homes outside have a
dark color and then white trim what are
you talking about I've rarely seen light
on top with dark home but I've never
seen it till this day and he was saying
that and I was telling him no that's I
didn't even mention you have white trim
panels yes and in like a color on top to
border it out and so and I I told him
this I didn't tell him that part all I
told was like it's an opinion how can my
opinion be wrong you asked me what color
I like and he was it's wrong you know
what you're saying you're telling me
that my opinion is wrong and I had he
had the silver tape recorder yeah and I
wanted to record it I was like fine I'm
gonna record this conversation I'm show
you how stupid you look
and so I hid that tape record and he's
just it's just a tape recorder of being
him yelling back at each other all I'm
looking for is it one of those small
ones were you all see other ones so I'm
looking for that tape recorder so I
could listen back to our argument when I
was like 8 years old with me and my dad
and it was just something so stupid you
know why our parents never learned
reasoning like in the sense of the
Western sense of logic yeah yeah and be
so like if you think if you think about
the way they reason right like they
don't reason with facts yeah a fact to
them can be their friend's opinion yeah
or what they choose to believe like it's
not scientific evidence and they to them
like scientific evidence is as like
wishy-washy as someone's opinion to them
it's it's in the same like they don't
care if something can happen over and
over and over and there's evidence yeah
that weighs just as much as my friend
said this to and he thinks that like
that's why their mind is not clear of
what has weight and what doesn't just so
hard to conversate with them dude
there's a lot of things that I've picked
up from my dad for example that habit of
always trying to win an argument even if
you're wrong
that I learned that I did that I did
that when I was younger a lot and I
picked that up being in relationships
and I started to realize yo I'm arguing
with this girl
because so it would be on some [ __ ] of I
know I'm wrong but you gotta win and it
you know when it finally clicked yeah
you gotta get rid of that so I'm trying
to get rid of it and I'm yo miracle what
makes you a [ __ ] dude like if you don't
know how to [ __ ] come to a conclusion
and you're you just can't reason it's
like it's it's [ __ ] it makes you look
dumb
it's the habit of thinking everybody
else in the world is dumb and you're the
only smart person in the right and I
didn't want to be that person I wanted
to be that person that could say I'm
sorry I wanted to be the person that
could say oh [ __ ] I was wrong then and
then reflect back on it and then accept
that and move on and I Muriel has to
deal with that [ __ ] right now so I'm
gonna be the person that learns yeah
like oh I'm doing myself a distance to
myself if I'm stubborn
I'm prolonging my ability to learn so
like my dad had this thing we're like we
would fight and he's like why can't you
just be normal and I'm all like what
defines normal and I'm asking in the
most respectful way possible because if
he has a criteria and definition for
what he thinks is normal then I
understand what he expects out of me
yeah but he gets even wait he gets even
more mad like he's like you don't know
you don't have common sense and I'm like
what the explain it [ __ ] like
what are you saying what is normal
yeah and then like he can't explain it
and then I'm like that makes you an
idiot because you expect everyone to
just know yeah but you're obviously the
person here with more life experience so
you to you your job is to teach right
yeah and then that's when I think I
outsmarted my parents I was like okay
I'm a child but you're a [ __ ] idiot
man who there's this one time I
specifically remember I was like in
fifth grade yeah and then I think I
learned about we we learned about the
Renaissance in in in Europe right so
after the Dark Ages came the Renaissance
yeah and then science came and they're
like all these revolutions started
happening
and then I was like these new schools of
thought emerged in Europe mm-hmm and
then I was trying to explain to my dad
like oh you know why like European
society is different from Japanese
society is because I think in Japanese
society we never had our Renaissance and
we never had our kind of like like
different schools of thought and then
like things to kind of challenge
Christianity and things are you saying
Japanese people are dumb yeah that's
exactly what he said to me it's like
he's like jagged bad are you you you
[ __ ] you're not proud of being
Japanese and I'm like oh my god are you
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like man he said he would've been great
on Twitter nowadays as a young person
that's like what that's what like what
to do yeah man I was just trying to have
a discussion I'm like I didn't realize
what a [ __ ] stupid as he was until
that point dude I was like wow it's
funny cuz I feel like with my dad he's
super smart he's hyper intelligent he's
just stubborn as [ __ ] and so for him
it's like you know I'm right and you
know I you know you know I'm right yeah
on these type of things yeah you just
don't want to say it you just don't want
to say it man so he makes up all these
reasons to win yeah and that that's my
mom has to deal with that too and like I
said I've picked up that habit too which
I'm trying to break like I don't do it
with strangers a lot but I do do it with
with my relationships will I do with
Mary Oh a lot or even if let's say I'm
right I don't have to point out how
right I am you know like I don't have to
yeah like I I just I have to find a
reason where I'm just like oh god you
know I'm a little right though and it's
such a bad habit of mine I'm trying to
break this I think it comes from feeling
disrespected yeah it has nothing to do
with being right or wrong it's just you
feel disrespected so now you got to win
people don't understand how the things
that you do to your kids at a very young
age it sticks with them for the rest of
them yeah we're like sponges I feel like
we spend the rest of our lives getting
rid of our parents bad habits yeah I'd
like a lot of the stuff that I picked up
is even stuff that they're trying to get
rid of it just it just it just bled over
into me like I'm trying to get rid of
that like me getting rid of my hot
temper was the hardest thing to do and I
grew up with hot-tempered parents yeah
my mom is [ __ ] hot temper dude I saw
my mom throw a loaded
rice cooker at my dad's head you got it
but you have any idea the type of race
that you have to throw dinner at
somebody that's [ __ ] wild she threw a
fool of fully filled rice cooker at my
dad and that's why I'm like Asians are
supposed to be [ __ ] Zen and
intelligent and that's right [ __ ] nah
why do we act like a bunch of animals
man like you know it's crazy like um the
funny thing is now I know why we need
martial arts and Zen Buddhism and all
these other things cuz like you need to
meditate there's no one up the growing
up like this you need to figure out how
to find peace in your soul cuz you just
have so much [ __ ] anger Jam and like I
really that hold meditate I'm trying to
meditate man I'm actually trying to
meditate at least at least once a day
that's yeah that's one of those goals
but it's been so [ __ ] cold I ended up
just meditating
I don't meditate it's hard to meditate
what it's cold as [ __ ] man
I think that's the hardest thing to
control your own mind yeah look we're
not taught that right like you're not
taught how to control your feelings and
your thoughts and because our parents
don't understand like they don't know
that it's something that they can do
yeah maybe now after like 70 years I
feel like I'm lucky that at 30 I
understand that and there are a lot of
people that are out there preaching that
and teaching that but I think immigrant
family is again like they're not
educated they're not not saying everyone
is like this there are people that and
we know some I think in our generation
the typical immigrant parent that wasn't
they didn't have that traditional
Western education yes um yeah we can't
have that conversation now now it's a
different time it is different you know
we had a lot of our parent for blue
collar workers yeah you know you when we
say that too we're talking about our
generation my parents were college
educated - man yeah just but hell yes
but the thing is they went to a private
college like a Christian University and
in you know like yeah reasoning conflict
resolution all these things like it's
not taught even in white society it's
not taught like if you think about the
Bible Belt and
conservative old-school like white
families right yeah like they they still
beat their kids they still do all that
[ __ ] and it's like they don't encourage
much thinking and speaking but at least
in Western society they have science and
they have the concept of debate so so
you know the way their justice system
works and all that it's based off of
debate reason and truth yeah right so
like their society is a little bit more
geared toward it's okay to express your
thoughts and and and battle it out
through words where that never evolved
in Asian society where we grew up with
Confucianism even if we're Christian its
deeply rooted in our culture and
Confucianism is just blindly listening
to the person above you and being a good
obedient servant toward that and in
following the structure right you have
government at the top and then you have
the father the mother the oldest sibling
and and so forth and we're just supposed
to listen because they have wisdom and
we have to respect that's too hard for
me it is so they don't understand the
concept of debate they see it as you're
challenging their authority I mean think
about it dude like it's hard for them to
even like like so in to be a good Asian
parent right you structure the life of
your child you you tell them what school
to go with go to you you tell them what
career to have you tell them who to
marry like you tell them and in and it's
because you use all the wisdom that you
you have and you go okay like I kind of
[ __ ] up here and there so you do it
this way and in the next generation they
get all that information and then they
tell their kids that yeah that's the
structure but when we come to America we
we don't do it that way
yeah I'm kind of blessed in the sense of
I feel my parents evolved a lot like
they definitely had their evolution
stage um which allows me to have a
better relationship with them I think it
comes with age - it does they start to
realize yo I wasted a lot of time on
[ __ ] yeah
I kind of messed up on that kind of case
cuz my mom I remember her telling me
that I had to marry a Korean girl and
that she still got her way though she
still got away he's gonna you know real
serious relationship yeah she um she
wanted me to I and I understood why it's
because she did it she wanted to be able
to have a relationship with whoever I
was going to marry because it would be
her daughter-in-law she can't speak
English you know and for her she I think
if she would have communicated that to
me like it would be nice yo yo I said
that too I was like you've lived in
America for like 30 years yeah how come
you never learn English she goes my mom
she's she's not even done she just goes
mom's too stupid no no no no that's an
excuse you're not too stupid you just
you just chose not to you specifically
chose not to yeah she doesn't even drive
do my dad a driver everywhere well I was
like man I feel so bad I feel so bad
that I can't communicate with Jess and I
don't know English and I'm like well you
could learn and she's like I know but I
don't want to yeah yeah yeah I don't
know yeah I mean well and I guess is
easier for just to probably know
Japanese than it is for her to learn
English yeah I mean my mom knows a lot
of English she just intimidated she just
feels embarrassed like she's like oh I
should know already I spent so many
years in that country and my well my mom
doesn't know like english besides do you
want to buy do you like you know like
the basic english mom was a receptionist
and i'm like how do you not be yeah how
do you not speak english your
receptionist you have to pick up phone
calls yeah and then you're telling me
you can't speak English come on and you
can speak I'm so glad that I could speak
freely to like my aunt and my mom like
the way that I can because it's very
jokey I don't think a lot of people
speak to their relatives like the way I
do yeah cuz like my odd over
Thanksgiving she's so obsessive
she's like stupidly obsessive over stuff
that doesn't [ __ ] matter for example
we're here and she sees that I have a
plant outside she goes you have a plant
outside I'm like yeah I have a plant
outside she goes but it's so pretty why
don't you bring it inside I'll say
because he was dying inside so I left it
outside and it's doing better she goes
you should bring it inside I'm like hey
it's my [ __ ] plan if I want to leave
that plant outside if I want to put
gasoline on it and light it on fire like
the burning bush in the Bible I will
[ __ ] do it
I don't you shut up about the plant
right she goes okay
it's your plant and I'm and then as he
goes let's you should bring it in she
does some [ __ ] petty [ __ ] like this
she stands right over there at the
kitchen looks stares out the window she
goes what a shame only if there was a
plant as if I can't here create I'm like
shut up I was like do you want me to go
outside to step on the plant I'll kill
the plant right now she goes why is such
a beautiful pie dude you're stressing me
out dude if you talk about this plan one
more time I was like I'm gonna suplex
the [ __ ] out of you dude and so and are
you guys fooling around this whole time
guys that's how we taught yeah like I
told her like I'm gonna throw her
outside and then she's like cracking up
I'm cracking up - I'm just like you're
so weird I was like how do you still
obsess about small things like this even
when I'm thirty years old and so after
that like her her middle child
she's he's eating he's 30 he's my age
yeah so he's easy he's not eating that's
what I'm saying he said he's like
chewing on a few things already got a
few things it's not really because he's
gonna have his own Thanksgiving friend's
gaming dinner at his apartment later and
so she goes how come you're eating and
it's like he's like oh honey with my
friends she was oh you should eat
something he goes I can't because I'm
gonna eat a third dinner then because I
already ate something before this she
was okay
well she I looked at her I was like
leave him alone he is an adult go away
and so I literally got up and I pushed
her out the way I put her back in the
kitchen go talk about the plant now
that's another thing forceful Asian moms
are hilarious dude like so like my mom
and her friends also they're all the
same they'll be like hey you hungry or
you want this or you want that and I'm
all like tell me what you want me to do
cuz I'm gonna tell you what my point is
is you're not gonna listen you just
gonna do what you want don't know no no
no no and then they'll be like you want
this snack I'm like no and then they'll
bring it over opening it for me drop it
like eat it and I'm like God what yeah
if you want
do it just say it you know I already
told my mom because she brought it up to
me not too long ago she asked do you
think that you can live with me in the
future and I asked her are you asking me
because you want to or you know
absolutely I cannot I was like you know
the answer to this don't you yeah and
she goes this is true I know I can't
live with you I was like you exactly
because I and I mentioned to over
Thanksgiving I told her something small
this is my house my house my rules right
same thing at your house your house your
rules I just stayed over here yeah I was
at my house my my rules right she goes
yeah okay okay how about this how come
what I told you to not hand wash
everything and just put it in the
dishwasher because that's what I'm gonna
do anyways why did you hand wash
everything for us a habit yeah yeah and
you just put the place everywhere drying
it around like it's a t-shirt everywhere
and like in the house why did you do
that
she put plates all over the house drying
it I'm like why did you do that right
she goes because that's how I do it but
I just told you my house my rules do it
this way it's easier for me cuz I have
to clean it up yeah as she goes it's
better this way this is why I can't live
with you crazy person you are a crazy
person that's what I call I call crazy
lady house hey crazy lady what'd she do
she just left just laughs about it she
looks just how mommy is I'm like I know
this is why we can't live together yo
crazy for so would you rather have her
like have a like let's say like way in
the future right yeah she has nobody
like look at your dad pass or whatever
she's by herself
yeah then it's different yeah she if my
dad passes away before her which she's
six years old and my dad so I don't
think that's gonna happen I think my dad
will outlive her oh yeah but I was this
is not me trying to say be mean or
anything my dad should pass away before
my mom because I think my mom could
survive better without him than the
other way around that's most couples
yeah I think that's what it is right
because I or I hope they pass away close
within each other
mm-hmm because my dad is my dad's best
friend is my mom yeah you know like it
kind of reminds me of like like Bart geo
situation yeah like Bart and geo have
each other they're they're very like
dependent very hyper
in the most positive and beautiful way
yeah and so like we see couples like
that too like Nicky and Steve they're
hyper they're high burn codependent on
each other
like I feel like when when when they
went off into like Cancun or whatever
but we're talking to see this thing was
like I don't know what to do with myself
so just like sitting on his bed going
like yeah you know he's because he's
used to being around his lady and they
spend a lot of time with each other and
that they're they they work at home they
see each other everyday and they coexist
like that yeah
Muriel is Marilyn are very different she
has her own set of friends I have my own
set of friends and even her parents like
that they coexist in that type of way
yeah they spend a lot of time with each
other but they have a lot of other
people to connect with and so when I see
that I'm like okay maybe my mom should
definitely outlive my dad yeah cuz I
wouldn't know I don't know if he has
anybody to talk to her confide in to
aside from my mom because there's
there's me we talk but half the time I'm
try not to fight him
you might chill out I'm hoping dude I'm
hoping one day he'll chill out it's been
60 years yeah still hasn't so let's
let's say well he's mellowed out a lot
yeah it's not as angry with age comes
realization yeah my mom hasn't mellowed
out though she's [ __ ] angry [ __ ] all
the time
hopefully he goes to the male menopause
and the [ __ ] estrogen starts coming
in and he feels more emotional and
relaxed when I was back in Sacramento my
mom my mom asked my dad to get a bottle
of vinegar yeah because she's trying to
make this persimmon vinegar type of
thing and so this is how my mom reacts
she always goes zero to a hundred even
til this [ __ ] day she she my dad goes
to the store he comes back with the
bottle of vinegar like about like like a
medium-sized bottle right the first
thing she says she goes what the hell is
wrong with you
how would you get this sighs why she's
screaming and I look at my mom and I'm
like chill why are you yelling at him so
much he looks I always does it the wrong
way and I look at my dad isn't that
every relationship though guy goes out
to get some [ __ ] and comes back it's the
wrong and I look at my dad and my dad's
eyes are just glazed over
I don't care
yell at you like this all the time is in
trouble because you just noticed this
it's been like this for 60 years my
dad's like it's been like this forever
he goes I just let her yell because I
don't care anymore my mom who's laughing
as I stop yelling at him I was like you
can't even drive you you you wouldn't
even be able to get it yourself yet if
you wanted to yeah he got you the thing
I'll she goes why wanted a bigger one is
cheaper I was like so it works it's
still good she was yeah so it was the
same exact one it was just a different
side yeah yelling at the do for you
angry Avery woman you know she just
cracking up and laughing I was like
insane yeah I told her like dude I
cannot be with so I I'm surprised you're
married that's why I looked at my mom
surprised you found somebody to take
your crap that's it he's yelling at
people for no reason
yep that's not my pants dude how do you
live with so much pressure dude we had
so much yelling in our house yeah just
yelling at the top of their lungs and
Merrill they don't really girl grow up
with that oh she didn't so she doesn't
argue like that confident conflict
resolution wasn't something she learned
I think do they just is that the family
or do you think their family like
berries things a lot because it goes one
way or the other in Asian families it's
either that they bury or they're [ __ ]
hella dysfunctional yeah and very rarely
you have a well-balanced family that
talks things out yeah I was the
dysfunctional yelling family breaking
rice cookers punching holes in the wall
shattering [ __ ]
breaking glass is that yeah dude it was
chaos in our house man sometimes I look
back like if I'm pretty sure if one
let's say like one white precious stay
with us for a week they would run the
[ __ ] away like through these people or
eating smelly food and they're punching
people in the face I can't I can't take
this
we're like zoo animals man yeah [ __ ]
monkeys throwing dishes on the walls
yeah they didn't know how to deal with
their emotion well and I didn't know how
to deal with my emotions very because we
were never taught and that transferred
over took school yeah why I got into
fights get into [ __ ] hella fights dude I
got removed from my first school because
I stabbed the kid in the face and I
prior to that I had three fights before
that just fist fights cuz I used to get
a lot and it wasn't I wasn't a tough guy
it's just kids would Punk me all the
time and I got sick
yeah so I just started swinging back at
people and might now and by the way that
was to the advice of my father all right
my dad was named you're a kid too yeah
like what am I supposed yeah and then if
you have a violent home it's like like I
got kicked out of the Chess Club because
I [ __ ] the kid kept cheating so I
grabbed the chess table and I threw it
and [ __ ] swipe the pieces and and and
I threw a fit and I thought I was in the
right because they were cheating yeah
but I was never taught like hey control
yourself yeah if you get angry you know
like come talk to us because my parents
[ __ ] get angry and they don't control
themselves yeah they're just dude you
know those drug free red bracelets
mm-hmm
they would like stay drug-free and you
had the red bracelet on your wrist it
looks like that [ __ ] that you get at a
club when you go in it yeah or like a
festival or some [ __ ] and this dude took
it took it off and he kept whipping me
with that [ __ ] while I was in class
while the teacher the one that that
expands and it goes in and he came would
be made of like metal or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah I was like time to stop and I got
so [ __ ] mad like I was like stop
cut it out quit it and he would kept
doing and laughing when the teacher
wasn't looking and so you but - you're
the desk filled with [ __ ] like books
of [ __ ] I tried to lift it and throw it
at him throwing the books at him
smashing on his head and the teacher
sent me to the office and I and I went
to the office and I talked and I showed
them my wrist I was I kept whipping me
and the teacher wouldn't do anything
about it yeah and she thought I was
being trouble but look at my arm it was
like super red because he kept whipping
me with that [ __ ] and one of the things
I felt that I I hated a lot and I was
talking to this when Merrill's best
friend because she deals with children a
lot
she teaches like what's it called what
do you call elementary school no
elementary school students yeah and she
she she says that that was an issue that
I think a lot of educators are learning
now where they weren't taught to listen
to children and what they're going
through
yeah and I always felt that was unheard
because I just get bullied a lot it's
like you're just wrong yeah you're just
wrong you're wrong cuz you got into
conflict yeah both of Europe yeah it's
it's no there is somebody that is
clearly wrong and you guys need to help
me fix it and they made me feel like I
was a bad person
yeah as a kid I used to get into fights
all the time because I felt that I was
gonna get persecuted either way so
[ __ ] you might as well protect
yourself yeah you're in your spirit like
these dudes are bullying me you're
telling me I'm wrong I'm just gonna
[ __ ] smash this kid's teeth in like I
don't give a [ __ ] dude I got it the
worst thing I ever did in elementary
school is I literally follow the kid to
the bathroom cuz he kept throwing
foursquare balls at me and I pushed him
down in the bathroom and I just kept
stomping on his [ __ ] face in the
bathroom over and over and over because
I wanted him to cut that [ __ ] out and I
just went red and that's how I learned
how to solve my issues but then you know
they say you're wrong for acting too
excessive and I didn't care because I
was gonna get in trouble
either way yes I was gonna get bullied
and I was gonna get in trouble so I
might as well say I feel like the person
who provokes is that fault they don't
want to find out yeah
and it was weird too because the people
that I got they started picking up a
pattern and the reason why I started
getting not getting away with it as if I
was wrong they started to understand the
kids that I got into a fight with were
all troublemakers they were all
troublemakers they were the ones that
were bullying everybody but I was the
one [ __ ] huge asian kid that fought
back you can't fight back and they were
like hold on a second so he's he's
fighting with these three kids who are
constantly delinquent yeah maybe it's
not him finally they find out yeah after
like fifth sixth grade they're like oh
[ __ ] there's there's a bigger issue here
this kid just has violent tendencies and
he's fighting back so they're dealing
with children differently now [ __ ] yeah
I hope so they're learning like how to
sit them down and like talk it out and
figure out yeah you know don't just
punish them like ask them how they're
feeling what's going on in their house
they're learning methods to deal with
kids who have a TD yeah you know they
have teaching them how to do mindful
mindful breathing yeah like that's crazy
I wish I was taught [ __ ] like that sits
a desk like chilling areas tell just
grind my teeth and I'm like wait till
the bell rings [ __ ] I'm gonna
punch you in the face yeah you know and
in front of the teacher I'm like all
like nice and [ __ ] and you just learn
how to be manipulative because you feel
like the system doesn't work for you
that's that's the first thing I learned
in elementary school is that the system
doesn't work for you and people don't
care yeah because and I mean to their
credit to like we're talking about
overcrowded classrooms teachers that are
unfit and like they don't know how to
deal with these kind of new students
yeah like like I'm you know there's
older teachers that like they came from
a generation where students were a
little boy they were more well-behaved
they came from good homes yeah we're the
last you know latchkey generation where
our parents were busy working yeah we
didn't have anybody to take care of us
like hella sugar hella crazy lifestyle
you know and then like they didn't know
what a TD was they didn't know what
asked like Asperger was they don't know
what autism was like you know like all
those stuff were too it was too new and
they were untrained you know with a lot
of I don't want to say a lot I just know
from my own personal experiences where I
had to have conversations with parents
especially as a youth pastor where these
parents didn't want to accept the fact
that something could be wrong with their
kid they would rather have their kid
deal with their issues of a DD whatever
OCD you know some kids were clearly
autistic and they they wouldn't allow us
to say hey you might have to check your
kid for these type of things and they go
no there's nothing wrong with him it's
not even wrong yeah it's just like it
happens it used to do bro it used to
[ __ ] it's like don't you love your
kids and want to accommodate for them
because it's not for you if we get
you're doing it for yourself yeah you
don't want people to say this your kid
quote unquote in their mind is [ __ ]
you know how they would say it in Korean
yeah that is so wrong cuz you're trying
to protect your image and you're not
thinking about your child at this point
we're not saying there's something wrong
with this like as in a negative thing is
that there's an issue that needs to be
fixed
yeah you know and you just help
accommodate for the way they think yeah
I mean the thing is a DD ADHD autism
Asperger's all these things it's been
around for a very long time they just
figured out now that it's like a thing
but it was it's not a disease it's not
something that's wrong with them it's
just like we categorize it now we know
we identify it now so we can accommodate
to that learning
style yeah there was you know as
somebody at the church who this kid I
mean he went to a Korean church so the
in Korean churches there's this thing of
like I don't want to call it bullying
but it's it's tough love and if you take
the tough love yeah it's called it's
called um hazing yeah they hazing me and
then after you take the hazing for
whatever amount of time they accept you
into the group that it's all good I mean
that's true with Japanese and yeah yeah
we we do a pretty hardcore version of
that there was some camaraderie that
went on with that right and so like I
picked it up from them too
and I was like quote-unquote hazing this
younger kid and he took it so bad like
he was getting rekt from it and I didn't
understand why he couldn't compute what
we computed and then because my brother
he actually worked as a behavioral
therapist he told me that yo I think
that kid might be autistic and it might
just be coming off as bullying like
you're bullying this kid is autistic and
I started looking at the kid I started
reading into it of stuff and I took
notes for my brother another oh holy
[ __ ] I think he has autism yeah cuz as
he's who as he was getting older his
like mentally developed like his mental
development was stagnant it was still
you know so he it's like you guys grew
and then he didn't he felt like he was
still immature yeah and so I mean I was
like I was like what what seven or eight
years old than him right and that was
the same treatment that I got from the
older hyung's and I tried to do the same
for him and it wasn't like I wasn't
beating him up you know it was more like
dude you know it's like teasing
he's amazing yes you know and [ __ ] he's
like frat boys [ __ ] you know take them
out to eat after stuff to tell him like
yo man you're a good kid and stuff you
could do that type of stuff but he
didn't take it that way roasting on
whatever exactly and so I took it upon
myself to talk to his older sibling and
say hey my brother he works with kids
with autism and he thinks that maybe
your younger brother might have some
systems of being autistic and man that
[ __ ] did not take it well
[ __ ] lashed out at me something like
yo what the [ __ ] ways are you bullying
it but I know I'm not bullying him I'm
telling you right now that like you know
what's the same [ __ ] that you did to all
the other kids at the church yeah what
I'm saying is that you should you know
talk to your parents about it and their
parents were not happy with me at all
saying all you say my kids were taught
no it's not mental retardation like you
[ __ ] yeah no this is like some serious
[ __ ] yeah so after a while they started
noting noticing after like a year
[ __ ] past which may said all that
time wasted all that time and you could
have nipped it in the bud where I you
know my brother told me like the earlier
you catch it on the more you could help
yeah because they they're gonna learn
different it yeah worked with that
behavior it was like a year or two or
whatever I can't remember the time span
but they wasted all that time because
they were stuck in their pride I'm
saying they they didn't understand it
and they didn't want to listen to people
that [ __ ] infuriated me because I like
that kid a lot and you know kids still
sweet till this day but definitely when
I look at him I think like mentally in
terms of mental development he could
have been helped out more if they would
have just addressed it at that time and
they would have put their pride aside
yeah and that's something that they have
to live with and I I just felt it sucks
because that's a cultural thing - I wish
mental health was more dealt with in the
Asian community a little bit better yeah
definitely cuz I feel like it's only a
small educated group of people that
understand it like in academics like I
mean I'm sure I'm sure like people that
go to like Seoul University or some [ __ ]
like they're not stupid to the house
right like and they're gonna treat it
differently but on the whole scale of
everybody like the general public
they're kind of stupid when it comes to
this kind of stuff yeah cuz it's like
they look at it like like my kid doesn't
have AIDS you don't immediately yeah
it's not even bad man what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
they look at therapy as if like oh
you're freak you know like people just
need somebody to talk to and bounce
their ideas off of it not everybody has
the the strong group around them or they
can openly speak to each other and
really relieve their stress and they
shouldn't trust their friends cuz their
friends are idiots yeah you know like
yeah none of my friends are odd autism
experts or [ __ ] yeah like how do we
know
ATD experts or why am I gonna ask them
they don't know [ __ ]
yeah like I'm not sure if their parents
talked to somebody else and I hope David
that young man's so disrespectful I told
you this is from my brother who's a
behavioral therapist yeah but
again parents that don't listen to facts
yeah so their mind doesn't know how to
take that yeah they don't know how to
take information man he had it that's
all it is he had like an inkling of it
before well I'm obviously a lot more
verb like I speak up a lot more than him
and then you know when I had that
conversation with I mentioned him again
he goes yeah he probably does and we
should you know look at it or discuss it
and I think that's that's the whole
reason why I like kids or like Asian
American immigrant kids born born from
immigrant parents right yeah a lot of
these conflicts a lot of the [ __ ] that
people go through all the fighting all
that it comes down to them not
understanding how to reason like not
understanding the difference between
facts and opinion and all these simple
things that we pick up and learn they
don't they just don't get it yeah that's
why I like you they took it personally
offensive yeah like I attacked them yeah
I mean that's a stupid seven-year-olds
response to something that's scientific
right and that that dude - he's in a
younger generation you know he's like a
couple years old than me yeah he
shouldn't have taken like that like the
[ __ ] are you talking about dude you know
he's born to parents like that yeah like
that don't believe in science that don't
believe in like that he was kind of
stupid too because well he literally
said that I called his brother [ __ ]
when you didn't say that you were just
basically like he didn't know what
autism was and he said and I called him
[ __ ] so instead of saying what's
autism yeah he could have asked me what
it was I get offensive yeah almost a yo
talk to my older brother and that that
goes back to my dad like I talked to him
about the Renaissance and he's like so
you think Japanese people are [ __ ]
stupid yeah it's the same jump into
conclusions kind of [ __ ] man yeah
it's it's tough and I think a lot of our
fans specifically go through a hard time
because I always say this like once you
become smarter than your parents yeah
you can't read you can't talk to them
anymore because you can't have
discussions you can't have anything and
then what these kids try to do is
convince them yeah cuz they think oh
well maybe if I tell my parents some
factual things or some studies or
evidence maybe they'll listen no they're
not gonna listen because they know their
mind is not wired to taking information
that way yeah it's it's learning how to
deal with the situation based on the
person that you're dealing with exactly
which is a skill that a lot of us have
to learn is a skill that I'm still
learning till this day and I'm getting
better at right now there are certain
situations though that I will say there
are younger people who are in this
category of expecting expecting too much
out of something that they didn't do
their due diligence for and what I mean
by that is I do see a lot of like
immigrant kids who have immigrant
parents they want to have their cake and
eat it too because one thing that
immigrant parents do really well
they provide really [ __ ] well yeah
generally speaking they prepare are some
alcoholic losers out there but generally
speaking you're right there's like there
they work their ass off to give
everything for their gift and they don't
understand this too
I told the story before I I was at UCSD
I believe and I was so this kid
basically came up and he was like amen
uh so what do you think about you know
parents not really supporting your
dreams like I hate my parents and you
know they don't want to support me of
what I want to do bla bla he's just like
trashing his parents like you know in a
public crowd and whatever right I was
like okay cool well let me ask you this
man what do you want to do bro he goes
oh I want to be a singer man like I
wanna you know you know drop this collar
[ __ ] whatever become a singer I was like
cool that's great man I there's actually
a guitar right here it's a crown for
like 500 people I'm gonna give you your
chance to shine people whatever you come
up here and let's do it right and I was
like oh yeah yeah yeah he goes now I'm
good man I was like boom right there
that's the problem I was like you know
what what the biggest difference is
between you and your parents your
parents actually work hard you're here I
was like are you is your parents paying
for your college right now he goes yeah
so you're taking your parents money
right you're taking all your parents
money I'm pretty sure you have a car to
and you're driving it around that your
parents pay for and you're sitting over
here bad-mouthing them taking all their
[ __ ] money doing what they want to do
or whatever but you're too scared to let
go of their hand not take their money
but you still want to do what you want
you can't have it both ways
yeah if you really
really wanted that independence you
could say mom and dad I'm gonna go get a
job i'ma pursue my dream of being an
artist and I will do this and I
guarantee you you didn't take that time
to talk to your parents and the biggest
difference is is that you just sit here
badmouth your parents but your parents
won't do that to a group of strangers
you all right do I feel bad cuz when I
said the kid started bawling BAM he
started thinking alized [ __ ] yeah
because he just called his parents trash
it for a group of people for no [ __ ]
reason yeah cuz I don't like she's just
he's just being a brat he's got what I
see is someone stomping at the grocery
store saying I want it that's what you
think yeah that's basically what I saw I
mean what I hear when I when you tell me
that it made me mad because you can't
take take from your parents yeah and
then expect them to support you the way
that's their money yeah I mean there's
people out there that are like my
parents are crack addicts yeah
and they still don't talk that kind of
[ __ ] to them yeah and it's like you
don't you know if you want to experience
empathy from your parents too you have
to give empathy too at the same time I'm
not saying it works all the time it
takes time like I had a dude it took a
lot of time with my parents you know we
had to break down walls consistently
over and over and it takes over it takes
a lot of work a lot of heartache and
works working and a lot of people I
think I remember being 18 I remember
being that age like you just want the
warmth and support that you see some of
your friends get from their house so I
totally understand the anger the
resentment the feeling of [ __ ] man why
can't my parents just be [ __ ] cool
like like [ __ ] Jon's parents man yeah
and then you see this a lot of white
kids like that's why you grow up
thinking white kids kind of have it all
right like cuz like you they have their
parents that that that [ __ ] kiss them
off to school and then they're like
whatever you want you want to be a
musician I'll do this to you right or
whatever and then you wish you had that
kind of support so then you a lot of the
kids immigrant kids I think they grow up
resenting it like they see like a better
example of what a parent is and then
they resent their own parents like [ __ ]
why can't you be like loving like them
yeah
and I think that's what happens man
but they don't get the the generational
work it takes to get there
so I guarantee you that white kids great
grandparents I bet you somewhere in
their family line they had some [ __ ]
strict ass abusive ass Irish potato
farmers that were like what the [ __ ] you
think you're gonna go and be a banjo
player [ __ ] and then they beat
their kids or whatever and then you know
talk about generationally now they learn
like okay like we shouldn't do that and
then we're gonna kiss our kids off to
school and do all these other [ __ ] like
I think that's what that's what that is
like you'reyou're just witnessing
something that people learn generations
are just a couple head like they're a
little bit ahead of us but our kids our
grandkids are gonna be like that yeah
you got to take that leap you know you
can't it's like biting the hand that
feeds you yeah you know but you you you
you want that independence you want to
do what you want then you got to stop
taking that money for mommy and daddy
cuz that's the control that they have on
you you have to take that leap but I
think they see the other kids that get
financial support they get emotional
support they get all these things like
set up yeah so I think that's what they
want even though in reality you're right
man like they shouldn't take anything
yeah and they should just do it on their
own which builds better character I'm
not saying this to like I didn't I'm not
saying this not from personal spirits I
had to take that leap yeah I didn't talk
to my dad for a whole [ __ ] year I
moved out the house I stopped talking to
them I mean we'll get into the story
later on and at a different time but
essentially I took the clothes on my
back the guitar that I had I walked out
didn't talk to my parent doesn't it feel
that much better that you did it on your
own Yeah right like I had to do that and
in that when that happened to it taught
my parents a valuable lesson and I also
taught me a valuable lesson at the same
time number one it taught me how hard it
was to do it on my own that I was being
baby that I was that kid that was taking
from my parents and asking and saying
that I wanted to have it my way and I
couldn't do it so when I broke off from
that I I took a big lesson in life it's
[ __ ] hard and you had it pretty
[ __ ] easy even though you think even
though you thought you didn't and my dad
had to know I can't control my kid like
a puppet the way
I thought I could I got a support in the
way that I wanted that he needs to be
supported yeah so but I mean you broke
the generation thing right your kids not
gonna go through that yeah you're gonna
support them you're gonna help guide
them whatever yeah like I I kind of
already had a set in my head and I don't
know obviously I you know when Mary
Levitt and I have a kid
we'll figure that out but I will support
them in my heart right now what they
want to do but they have to do it a
hundred percent I mean you want good
work ethics exactly which is reasonable
yeah what our parents wanted out of us
wasn't reasonable it was just they
wanted to them it was reasonable but
they wanted total control yeah I'm gonna
set them up for success right so right
if they say I want to be a professional
juggler fine but if they're killing it
in the game yeah and they're like really
working hard then it's like great but if
he's saying I want to be a professional
juggler but just plays video games all
day and doesn't do [ __ ] then it's like
hey cuz I'm gonna nurture academia them
a hundred percent yeah I'm going to
nurture that side I'm gonna make sure
that they go to school i'ma make sure
during grade school that they're gonna
get their stuff done they're going to be
excelling in that [ __ ] but after I say
like when after 18 now it's your choice
but to this point
i'ma at least equip you with the weapons
and the tools that you need to be an
intelligent adult after that you could
make that choice do you want to become
the doctor lawyer businessman
communications major whatever right and
they go okay well during this time that
I was proud and I want to become a
musician cool well now you have that
choice to nurture that let me know how I
can help you out in that kind of case
and he might even find that out during
high school junior high but I'll do it
then I hope I don't be too controlling
I'm just like I want to go camping with
my kids that's all I think about go
camping we're gonna go fishing we're
gonna play a lot yeah up a little
paperclip hell yeah and I'm like I don't
I don't give a book I think that's what
I'm gonna say to my kids the most I
don't give a book
you make your own choices daddy I have a
fever
I don't give a [ __ ] your fever I got
into Harvard I don't give a f--- uh no
I'm happy for you I'll give up food
alright job well that's the end of this
podcast some good [ __ ] man that was good
really really good yeah I felt like it
was therapy for me too hell yeah going
back in history man I hope you all
forgive your parents man they're most of
them are doing the best they can hell
yeah for the most part
adios we are done Tiger House a tiger
belly but Eiger belly man but this is
genius brain podcast
peace out Joe see ya later